und jetzt das heute journal
mit kai soll richter und christian
sievers guten abend an einem
ausgesprochen guten tag für diktatoren
und terroristen
der syrische machthaber baschar al assad
hat grund zum feiern die terror miliz es
auch beide mussten nicht mal viel dafür
tun die kurdische minderheit im
nordosten von syrien hatte mit
unterstützung der usa den islamistischen
terror dort zumindest militärisch
besiegt dann zog ihnen amerikas
präsident über nacht den boden unter den
füßen weg gab quasi grünes licht für
eine massive militäroffensive der türkei
gegen die kurden und die werfen sich
jetzt in die arme des regimes in
damaskus
das ist eine zeitenwende mit politischen
folgen weit über syrien hinaus folgen
die wir alle spüren werden ein gau für
den westen
knapp ein drittel von syrien hatten die
kurden unter ihrer selbstverwaltung
damit ist seit vergangener nacht schluss
jetzt sind regime-truppen eingerückt ein
pakt mit dem diktator in damaskus als
letzter ausweg newport berichtet die
syrischen volks verteidigungs einheiten
gwg seit sieben jahren sind sie der
sicherheitsgarant für das politische
projekt der syrischen kurden im
nordosten des landes eine
selbstverwaltung zu errichten an der
seite der amerikaner bezwangen sie die
blutrünstigen terroristen des
islamischen staates
viele von ihnen zahlen dafür mit dem
leben für die türkei aber sind sie
selbst terroristen verbündete der pkk
schon im letzten jahr schickte präsident
erdogan seine hochgerüsteten armee über
die grenze um die kurdisch bewohnten
stadt april zu besetzen
die kurden verhandelten mit diktator
assad ergebnislos vor der türkischen
überlegenheit mussten sie nach osten
zurückweichen im kurdengebiet zwischen
euphrat und tigris fanden annähernd
200.000 menschen aus den syrischen
kampfgebieten schutz
das ist vorbei seit der mann im weißen
haus entschied dass ein alles sinnlose
stammeskrieger aus denen amerika sich
heraushalten sollte türken und kurden
bekriegen sich seit zwei jahrhunderten
unmittelbar danach holte die türkische
offensive
die appelle der im stich gelassenen
kurden verhallen ungehört
wir bitten nicht um truppen
unterstützung aber wenigstens um eine
sperrung des luftraums wenigstens das
seither sind 130.000 menschen auf der
flucht brechen es terroristen aus
gefängnissen aus sterben jeden tag
zivilisten
heute dann kam die armee von diktator
assad den bedrängten kurden zu hilfe
ob diese vom krieg ausgezehrten
einheiten schutz gegen erdogans truppen
bieten bleibt abzuwarten wer wo in
nordsyrien das sagen hat das entscheiden
vermutlich demnächst putin und erdogan
man stehe im gespräch ist es heute den
preis für all das zahlen die kurden und
er ist hoch assad wird ihre
selbstverwaltung sicher nicht hinnehmen
sie stehen wieder bei null die kurden
waren wenn ich so sagen darf nützliche
idioten bei der bekämpfung der des
islamischen staates und werden jetzt
fallengelassen von den usa und es ist
ganz klar dass die kunden dieses nicht
vergessen werden und die europäer haben
in der region eigentlich gar nichts mehr
zu melden
irgendwelche aussagen aus berlin oder
brüssel nimmt man weder in ankara noch
in damaskus noch in moskau ernst die
türkischen soldaten marschieren weiter
wie ihr präsident heute betonte bis die
arbeit getan ist und der westen steht
ziemlich düpiert da das bisschen rest an
einfluss in syrien dürfte auf lange zeit
verspielt sein
die europäer versuchen druck zu machen
auf die türkei mit worten und weil sie
wohl selber spüren wie wenig das bewirkt
sagen sie gleich dazu dass es sehr
starke worte seien alle
eu-mitgliedstaaten haben die türkische
offensive einstimmig verurteilt betonung
auf verurteilt aus luxemburg stefan
leifert
große runde und doch wieder kleinsten
nenner überstunden suchen die
eu-außenminister nach einer antwort auf
den türkischen angriff am ende
verurteilen sie die offensive und rufen
die eu-länder auf waffenlieferungen zu
stoppen entscheidend ist dass wir diese
militärische invasion nicht unterstützen
durch die zulieferung weiterer waffen
das haben heute alle mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union bestätigt und das ist
das was unmittelbar wird kein generelles
waffenembargo keine
wirtschaftssanktionen kein ende der
beitrittsverhandlungen
die eu einigt sich auf starke worte
starke sanktionen bleiben aus unter nato
ländern geht indes die sorge um in den
krieg hineingezogen zu werden
sie wissen dass es ein artikel 5 gibt in
dem nato packt und der besagt wenn ein
land angegriffen wird müssen alle
anderen länder helfen das land zu
verteidigen stellen sich vor die die
türkei wird von serien oder alliierten
von serien angerufen
doch auch die nato fast die türkei nur
mit samthandschuhen an belässt es bei
appellen
[Applaus]
ich erwarte dass die türkei mit
zurückhaltung agiert und in abstimmung
mit den anderen nato partnern damit wir
die erfolge gegen unseren gemeinsamen
feind den es nicht gefährden
die nato braucht die türkei als
geostrategisch wichtigen partner im
osten
die eu braucht die türkei als teil ihrer
flüchtlingspolitik erdogan weiß beides
zu genau so kommen eu und nato heute
über appelle nicht hinaus europa
verordnet sich in syrien krieg auch
weiterhin die rolle des zuschauers aus
europa wenig hilfe die kurden schmieden
jetzt einen pakt mit dem diktator in
damaskus ali ertan toprak ist
bundesvorsitzender der kurdischen
gemeinde in deutschland der
interessensvertretung aller kunden in
deutschland hat ober guten abend guten
abend
es gibt auch viele kurden die sagen dass
sie jetzt angst haben müssen verfolgt
und gefoltert zu werden wenn assad kommt
warum machen sie das diesen pakt mit
damaskus
weil die kurden keiner anderer alter
teenie wir haben und der westen hat die
kunden alleine gelassen
die kunden haben sich sehr frühzeitig
für den westen entschieden für die
zivilisierte welt aber jetzt nachdem die
amerikaner abgezogen sind und die
europäer untergetaucht sind beliebt nur
dieser kompromiss mit assad und den
russen was wollen sie konkret von der
bundesregierung aktuell ganz konkret den
worten muss endlich die taten folgen
nur mit lippenbekenntnissen wird man
erdogan nicht aufhalten können
erdogan ist das trojanische pferd im
nato-bündnis das muss allen klar sein
das ist nicht nur eine tragödie für die
kurden sondern für die freie welt
erdogan wird weitermachen wenn man ihn
nicht stoppt er hat großmacht fantasien
er verfolgt eine neo osmanischen
ideologie hat stoppen wie soll die
bundesregierung kann erdogan stoppen
die türkei ist nicht irgendein partner
sondern nato mitglied und eu
beitrittskandidat und die eu und nato
haben viele möglichkeiten auf die türkei
einzuwirken
und was hat dieser diese zusammenarbeit
noch einen sinn wenn man keinerlei
möglichkeiten hat auf die türkei
einzuwirken
jetzt müssen wirtschaftliche sanktionen
knallhart und die sprache gesprochen
werden die eltern versteht und das ist
die sprache von macht und geld und
europa hat genug möglichkeiten und hebel
gegen erdogan vorzugehen
nur europa ist mutlos und verrät die
eigenen werte jetzt nicht noch
zusätzlich die eigene sicherheit der
fahrgäste sicher so dass es auch sehr
interessant ist dass die kunden auch
untereinander zerstritten sind können
sie mich hören ja ich kann sehr gut also
die kurden sind auch untereinander
zerstritten die türkei bekämpft die
kurden in syrien jetzt im moment ganz
massiv umgekehrt ist es aber so dass die
kurden im irak enge beziehungen zur
türkei unterhalten ist das nicht am ende
das grundlegende problem der kurden ja
stimmt bisher war das ein problem die
uneinigkeit der kurden
aber was erdogan mit diesem einmarsch
geschafft hat ist die einigkeit der
kunden wieder herzustellen und seit
längerem habe ich so eine einigkeit
unter den kurden nicht gespürt und
erdogan droht ja auch bereits jetzt den
kurden im nordirak wenn er hier in
nordsyrien seine invasions pläne beendet
hat wird er auch die kurden im nordirak
angreifen
sie packt ihren jetzt mit bascha
al-assad dem diktator in damaskus wenn
jetzt ein krieg droht assad gegen
erdogan was macht das mit den kurden
sie sprechen vom paktieren mit assad die
kurden waren die bodentruppen des
westens die kurden haben nicht nur ihr
eigenes territorium verteidigt sondern
auch die werte der freien welt und
unsere sicherheit in hier in europa hier
im westen
der westen hat die kurden jetzt
ausgeliefert nicht nur der türkei
sondern auch assad deswegen ist es nicht
in ordnung den kunden jetzt den vorwurf
zu machen diesen schuh müssten die
europäer die nato und auch usa anziehen
aber ich hatte gefragt was das für die
kunden bedeutet wenn jetzt ein viel
größerer krieg drohen könnte zwischen
syrien und der türkei
da werden sie noch zerrieben zwischen
beiden frauen ja aber jetzt was für eine
alternative haben die kurden
die kunden stehen vor einem genozid
erdogan will die kurden vernichten
in den ganzen tag über machte er
aussagen und bezeichnet die kunden sogar
als unmenschen und die kurden haben
keine alternative wenn sie überleben
wollen müssen sie auch neue strategische
partner suchen und beste wenn der westen
nicht dazu bereit ist bleibt den kurden
leider nichts übrig als mit assad zu
paktieren natürlich sind die kunden hier
zwischen den fronten aber sie haben
keine alternative ein gedanke noch an
uns hier in deutschland mit der bitte um
eine kurze antwort was macht all das was
wir in syrien gerade erleben mit dem
verhältnis kurden türken bei uns in
deutschland ja das verhältnis ist er
schon länger angespannt und wird auch
weiterhin angespannt bleiben und wir tun
als kurdische gemeinde deutschland alles
dafür dass die lage hier ruhig bleibt
und ich möchte auch an dieser stelle der
deutschen öffentlichkeit meinen dank
aussprechen im namen der kurdischen
gemeinde die großartige solidarität in
den letzten tagen die spüren wir die
bekommen wir mit und das ist ein kleiner
trost jetzt in der stunde der tragödie
aber ich bitte die deutsche
öffentlichkeit wirklich in den nächsten
tagen auch an den demonstrationen
teilzunehmen ihre solidarität zu zeigen
und druck ausüben auf die eigene
regierung es geht auch um unsere
sicherheit es geht um unsere
freiheitlich demokratischen werte in
europa die wir gemeinsam verteidigen
müssten sagt ali ertan toprak der
bundesvorsitzende der kurdischen
gemeinde in deutschland hat robot vielen
dank fürs gespräch gerne und damit zu
unserem nächsten thema alles wie immer
pomp and circumstance glanz und gloria
gold und glitzer die monarchien verließ
das regierungsprogramm ihres
premierministers das sind nicht ihre
worte das hat ihr boris johnson
aufgeschrieben es geht um briggs it
black city exit es ist derselbe boris
johnson der im parlament allerdings
keine mehrheit hat der seine gesetze
wenn überhaupt erst nach für ihn
erfolgreich neuwahlen durch bekäme der
mit brüssel in nervtötenden
verhandlungen feststeckt elisabeth die
zweite hat routine im verlesen von
vorhaben anderer es ist ihre 65 queen's
speech aber noch nie
hat eine regierung sieht dermaßen in die
zwickmühle gebracht wie die aktuelle
andererseits elizabeth wäre nicht
elisabeth wenn sie sich das hätte
anmerken lassen ja sind hier allein aus
london der wichtigste satz kam ziemlich
gleich am anfang
es war immer die priorität meiner
regierung den austritt des vereinigten
königreichs aus der eu zum 31 oktober
sicherzustellen
für ihre regierung hat der praxis also
vorrang
ob sie selbst das auch so sieht vermag
niemand zu sagen
das steht ja auch nicht zur debatte
keine miene zu verziehen ist eine der
herausragenden fähigkeiten der queen
scharfer beobachter oben jedoch hervor
dass die königin ein wenig missmutiger
dreinschaute als sonst nachdem es mit
der kutsche vom palast zum parlament
gegangen war
dass die queen nach dem fiasko mit der
unrechtmäßigen zwangspause des
parlaments nicht so gut auf ihre
regierung johnson zu sprechen sei muss
dann auch im bereich der spekulation
bleiben
statt dem sich schon den prinz philip an
ihrer seite
prinz charles heute sei wohl bring dein
kind mit zur arbeit tag gewesen
twitterte da ein spaßvogel einer jedoch
schien sich daran zu erfreuen dass sein
regierungsprogramm darin so festlichen
rahmen verlesen wurde
der premierminister doch selten wirkten
prunk und pomp der traditionellen
parlamentseröffnung so sehr wie das was
sie eigentlich ist eine inszenierung 7
der 26 gesetzesvorhaben kreisten um den
dreck sieht es ging um fischerei
landwirtschaft und das ende der
zuwanderungs freizügigkeit an die eu
bürger im land aber diese versöhnlichen
worte meine regierung bleibt ihrer
versicherung treu eu bürger die ihr
leben hier aufgebaut und diesem land
viel gegeben haben das bleiberecht zu
gewähren
neu war das alles nicht auch nicht dass
johnston die königin kräftig am geld
baum schütteln dies da wurde viel
versprochen für das gesundheitswesen
schulen die polizei und infrastruktur
was die opposition erzürnte dies ist
doch alles
eine scharade eine lange liste von
versprechungen die der premierminister
gar nicht einlösen kann
denn sein weg zum drechselt wird dieses
land so viel ärmer machen wäre diese
rede nicht von der königin vorgetragen
worden hätte man sie auch für eine wahl
werbesendung der konservativen halten
können eine auflistung von dingen von
denen sie glauben dass sie ihnen stimmen
bringen wird denn was ich am nahen
horizont abzeichnet sind nach wie vor
neuwahlen egal ob es boris johnson
diese woche gelingt doch noch einen deal
mit brüssel zustande zu bringen
denn es ist keineswegs sicher dass
dieser dann auch vom parlament abgenickt
wurde nach der zumutung von heute muss
es für die queen selbst vorrang haben
sich aus dem dreck schlamassel so gut es
geht herauszuhalten
die königin also als sprachrohr einer
instabilen regierung eine analyse der
queen's speech von unserer london
korrespondentin finden sie auch heute
dies und weitere wichtige nachrichten
von heute finden sie jetzt in ihrem
fernseher mit kaffee und da schauen wir
nach spanien dort hat der oberste
gerichtshof neuen katalanische
separatisten führer verurteilt zu neun
bis 13 jahren gefängnis
ihnen wird aufruhr vorgeworfen außerdem
wurde ein neuer internationaler
haftbefehl erlassen gegen den ehemaligen
katalanischen regionalpräsidenten
putschte mann der im belgischen exil
lebt hintergrund ist das katalanische
unabhängigkeitsreferendum von 2017 dass
die spanische justiz als illegal
einstufen
als reaktion auf die urteile gingen in
barcelona tausende katalanen auf die
straße nach dem terroranschlag von halle
will die cdu den kampf gegen rechten
terror verstärken die parteispitze
verabschiedete ein eckpunktepapier das
mehr möglichkeiten für ermittler vor
sieht außerdem einen besseren schutz
jüdischer einrichtungen und mehr
präventionsprogramme mit einem
ökumenischen gottesdienst wurde in halle
heute der zwei toten gedacht ein 27
jähriger hatte die beiden erschossen
nachdem er vergeblich versucht hatte in
die synagoge der stadt einzudringen
nach eigenen angaben handelte er aus
antisemitischen und
rechtsextremistischen motiven in
tunesien hat der jurist seit die
präsidentschaftswahlen gewonnen
laut wahlbehörde holte der parteilose in
der stichwahl knapp 73 prozent der
stimmen
der 61-jährige gilt in
gesellschaftlichen fragen als
erzkonservativ im wahlkampf hatte er
versprochen die korruption zu bekämpfen
und die verfassung zu überarbeiten damit
erreichte er vor allem junge wähler in
ecuador brannten heute keine barrikaden
sondern freudenfeuer nach tagelangen
unruhen feierten die demonstranten einen
teilerfolg präsident moreno will
treibstoff wieder subventionieren
zumindest vorerst mit vertretern der
indigenen bevölkerung will er nun eine
neue regelung erarbeiten die die ärmeren
schichten weniger hat
tagelang hatten vor allem indigener
einwohner gegen die verdoppelung der
spritpreise demonstriert oft gewaltsam
er gehört zwar nicht zu den preisen die
auf alfred nobel zurück gehen er wird
von einer bank gestiftet trotzdem gilt
der sogenannte nobelpreis für wirtschaft
als genauso wichtig dieses jahr geht er
an drei forscher für ihren einsatz gegen
globale armut die königlich schwedische
akademie der wissenschaften entschied
sich für den indoor abhisits manager
seine ev ist der diplom die einen
französischen und einen us pass besitzt
und den us-amerikaner michael krämer
die drei hätten unter anderem gezeigt
wie sich die gesundheit und bildung von
kindern mit kleinen präzisen schritten
verbessern lässt
aus polen heute das signal dass all das
am kurs des landes aus der europäischen
union so große sorgen macht weiter gehen
wird
mindestens es ist ein signal der
polnischen wähler
sie haben der regierenden
nationalkonservativen pis partei wieder
eine absolute mehrheit beschert im
parlament noch deutlicher als bisher
schon
und daraus folgt das signal auch an den
rest europas die hoch umstrittene reform
des gerichtswesens soll weitergehen noch
radikaler als bisher schon
da liegen sie hand an grundpfeiler der
demokratie und die wähler sagen dazu ja
oder neben das zumindest in kauf
diese wahl wird folgen haben in polen
und in deutschland deshalb beginnen
natalie steger und andreas kühner hasst
ihren bericht in berlin
die erklärung müsste auf polnisch sein
und fast 70 jahre alt aber sie ist
unauffindbar
im politischen archiv des auswärtigen
amts liegt jeder vertrag jede akte seit
1867 aber diese eine erklärung in der
polen auf reparationen verzichtet sie
ist nicht da war schon gestern abend der
triumph hat einen namen jaroslaw jahres
[Applaus]
wir haben jeden grund glücklich zu sein
trotz der enormen front gegen uns haben
wir es geschafft fast 44 prozent
kaczynskis pis partei legt noch einmal
zu mit ihrem programm gegen den
westlichen lebensstil gegen die schwulen
hier und gegen deutschland deutsches
zahlen die forderung der reparationen
ist nicht neu und nicht nur von
kaczynski aber sie zeigt wie seine
methode wirkt die methode
wir wollen unseren bevölkerung zeigen
dass wir stark sind dass wir den mut
haben deutschland gegenüber auch etwas
verwegene forderungen zu stellen
wir wollen polen von den knien wieder
auferstehen lassen das ist so dieses
negativ das dahinter steckt schon seit
vier jahren zeigt die pis wie sie aus
polen den starken staat machen will
ihren staat beispiel justiz als erstes
wurde das verfassungsgericht auf linie
gebracht dann mit einer großen
justizreform weite teile der justiz
brüssel konnte nur an kleineren
stellschrauben drehen indem es den eugh
anrief wenn dies auch noch den
präsidenten also die
präsidentschaftswahlen gewinnen dann
können wir davon ausgehen dass es wieder
zack auftakt geht und wieder gesetze
verabschiedet werden innerhalb von ein
zwei tagen und die nacht sitzungen die
wahl des präsidenten ist im mai
kaczynski will sie wieder mit nationalen
und sozialen themen gewinnen mehr geld
für familien für rentner höherer
mindestlohn der andere teil der methode
peace wir haben viel bekommen aber wir
haben mehr verdient wir brauchen noch
mehr ideen erfindungen die idee von
deutschland reparationen zu fordern
kommt aus dem parlament falls kaczynski
zustimmt könnte warschau mehr als 800
milliarden euro fordern
da schadet es nichts dass das berliner
politische archiv vergangene woche
diesen artikel im neuen deutschland
findet es ist zwar nicht polens
verzichtserklärung aber ein weiterer
beweis dass es sie gab und jetzt noch
mal kein server mit einem ferienflieger
in turbulenzen
aufatmen bei condor die eu-kommission
hat den staatlichen überbrückungskredit
für die deutsche airline genehmigt er
verzerre den wettbewerb in der eu nicht
übermäßig allerdings ist die auszahlung
an strenge auflagen geknüpft
die airline mit fast 5000 beschäftigten
galt bislang als profitabel steckt aber
wegen der insolvenz des mutterkonzerns
thomas cook in schwierigkeiten
deshalb helfen der bund und das land
hessen mit insgesamt 380 millionen euro
aus darf sich der chinesische
mobilfunkanbieter vorbei am deutschen g5
netz beteiligen oder nicht eine brisante
frage denn es geht dabei nicht nur um
wirtschaftspolitik sondern auch um
sicherheitsbedenken
nun berichten medien dass die
bundesregierung dem konzern nicht die
türe verschließen will
was heißt das genau stefanie bareth an
der frankfurter börse ja so wie es
aussieht wird der chinesische
telekommunikationskonzern huawei
tatsächlich komponenten für das
leistungsstarke 5 t netz in deutschland
zu liefern dürfen
sicherheitsexperten fürchten allerdings
vorbei technik könnte zum einfallstor
für chinesische spionage werden deshalb
drängen vor allem etwa die usa ihre
verbündeten dazu auf sie zu verzichten
japan australien neuseeland und taiwan
haben sperrklauseln dafür huawei
eingeführt die bundesregierung lehnte
das bislang ab und auch im neuen entwurf
zu den sicherheitsanforderungen in der
telekommunikation findet sich keine
sonderklausel huawei müsse wie alle
anderen konkurrenten nachweisen dass es
die sicherheitskriterien erfüllen heißt
es dort lediglich auf den ersten blick
mag dies wie ein einknicken gegenüber
dem mächtigen chinesischen
handelspartner aussehen
möglicherweise hat die bundesregierung
aber auch dem drängen der netzbetreiber
nachgegeben
telekom vodafone und telefonica hatten
sich vehement dafür eingesetzt huawei
nicht auszuschließen denn sie haben
milliarden in die 5g lizenzen investiert
und wollen so schnell wie möglich mit
dem netzausbau beginnen und sie brauchen
dabei huawei der chinesische
netzwerkausrüster ist nämlich nicht nur
weltweit führend seine produkte sind oft
deutlich günstiger als die der
europäischen hersteller
vielen dank
eine geschichte über den zufall irgendwo
geboren zu werden und was danach kommt
das ist der roman des jahres 2009 10
denn das buch herkunft wurde heute mit
dem deutschen buchpreis ausgezeichnet
darin erzählt die geschichte einer
familie die vor dem jugoslawien krieg
nach deutschland flüchtete ein blei
schweres thema federleicht erzielt so
die führung auch weil der leser selbst
über das ende entscheiden darf und jetzt
eine persönliche bitte von herrn bong
joon-ho der ist star regisseur aus
südkorea und sagt uns eindringlich bitte
nicht zu viel verraten von der handlung
meines neuen films sonst sein spannung
und emotion beeinträchtigt wer will
schon schuld seien daran dass spannung
und emotion leiden also ich nicht und
der mann hat ja recht denn die
wendepunkte seiner geschichte mal
bissige gesellschaftskritik mal amüsante
satire dann wieder suspense thriller
oder dramatischer klassenkampf all diese
wendepunkte muss man live erleben im
kino so viel nur vorweg von unserer
kritikerin sabine schulz sie sagt es ist
ein geniestreich die frau über uns hat
ihr netzwerk verschlüsselt
das wlan ist ausgeschaltet
familie kim ist bitterarm und lebt in
seoul in einer kellerwohnung sie sind
ganz unten angekommen
bis so ein kilo die chance erhält die
alles ändert oder willst du meine stelle
als ihr englisch nachhilfe lehrer
übernehmen muss ich zu tun als student
fehlt nur das passende diplom kein
problem für seine künstlerisch begabte
schwester ein studiengang
dokumentenfälschung will die tate
auszeichnung bestehen kiwo macht sich
auf den weg nach oben in das
nobelviertel der stadt die erschlichene
stelle bei der superreichen familie park
was für ein steiler sozialer aufstieg
kann das gut gehen
regisseur von schoko ist berühmt für
seine bissige kritik an unserer klassen
gesellschaft und für seine symbolische
bildsprache
achten sie mal auf die vielen treppen im
film sie stehen für die polarisierung
das soziale auseinanderdriften in
unserer gesellschaft nicht nur in korea
auch in deutschland in der ganzen welt
wird die kluft zwischen arm und reich
immer größer
von dieser erschreckenden entwicklung
erzählt mein film gemischt mit elementen
der komödie mit pechschwarzem humor
lässt regisseur bong zwei welten
aufeinanderprallen im durchgestylten
haus der parks herpa gleitet ein
unternehmen seine schöne frau kümmert
sich um die zwei kinder
bei der ersten stunde möchte ich dabei
sein
unser junger ist ein geborener künstler
wir haben im laufe der zeit wirklich
sehr viele kunst wäre bei uns
ausprobiert ich musste grad an jemanden
denken geschickt green key wo auch seine
schwester unter bei den parks als
vermeintliche kunsttherapeutin mit
herrlich perfiden tricks gelingt es den
teams die bisherigen bediensteten der
papst nach und nach loszuwerden und zu
ersetzen
bald wird sich die ganze familie käme im
haushalt der park sein müssten
das karussell der klassenkämpfe ist
eröffnet weil die zuschauer sympathie
für die hauptfiguren empfinden sind sie
eher auf der seite der armen familie und
offen es möge ihnen gelingen die reichen
zu infiltrieren
das ist ein effekt den nur das kino
erzeugen kann aber es gibt in diesem
film keine wirklich bösen und keine
richtig gute gerade das macht parasite
zu realistisch und brillant wie kann man
sowieso nicht hin sie ist nicht reich
und nett sie ist bloß nicht weil sie
reich ist weil sie es sich nämlich
leisten kann
parasite amüsiert erschreckt schockiert
völlig unvorhersehbar sozialsatire
parabel und thriller
ein film der in keine schublade passt
mehr soll hier nicht verraten werden nur
soviel parasite ist großes kino und
parasite also schmarotzer läuft ab
donnerstag bei uns im kino wir zwei sind
schon morgen also am dienstag wieder bei
hin wenn sie lust haben und zwar sehr
gerne
[Musik]
meine damen und herren der deutsche
wetterdienst hat eine gute nachricht die
dürre in deutschland ist beendet
jedenfalls im oberboden in tiefen von
etwa 1 meter 80 bis 2 meter allerdings
da fehlt immer noch wasser und deswegen
freuen sich bestimmt viele dass dieses
tief sebastian das morgen hier über die
nordsee und dänemark weiter in richtung
skandinavien zieht eben nicht nur wolken
mitbringt sondern auch wieder etwas
regen
der trifft morgen vor allen dingen den
westen deutschlands und später dann auch
den norden
und es ist eine kleine kaltfront die der
herankommt das merken wir noch nicht in
dieser nacht da bleibt es nämlich mit am
niederrhein
dort sinken die temperaturen nur bis 16
grad in bayern geht es dagegen zum teil
auf sechs oder fünf grad runter und an
der unteren donau bildet sich so auch
dichter nebel
an der nordseeküste fällt in der nacht
noch etwas regen und dann kommt die
kaltfront von tief sebastian von
frankreich heran bringt uns schon morgen
vormittag westlich des rheins etwas
regen im osten gibt es dagegen noch mal
ein schöner oktober tag mit viel
sonnenschein
am abend kommen dann diese regenwolken
langsam auch an der weser an dem
sauerland oder auch im schwarzwald kann
auch gewitter dabei sein
im osten bleibt es dagegen den tag über
noch trocken
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 17 grad an der ostsee und
darunter den regenwolken im westen und
bis zu 26 grad an der elbe in den
nächsten tagen schränken sich die
regenwolken im wesentlichen auf den
norden im süden wird es sonnig und mild
schöner